I think we need to come to terms with
the European Union without the United
Kingdom what it means to us
I actually think we're in a lose-lose
situation the UK will lose the European
Union will lose but we have to deal with
it we have to be pragmatic about it and
then obviously on the other side the UK
has to understand what is going on as
well and I don't think you're ready to
ignite article 50 negotiations or
anything like that at this stage yet I
mean at root for us was this whole
question of ever closer Union the fear
of the loss of sovereignty people talked
about getting their country back is that
how it feels in Finland as well do you
see the European Union as a threat to
your national identity no not at all I
think the whole sovereignty debate to be
quite honest is a fallacy I think the
European Union is about trying to find
common solutions to common problems
it's about pooling sovereignty I mean
none of us can leave I live isolated
anymore if I can no be as cruelest to
say it's a little bit like saying and
Donald Trump you know I will build a
wall while Mexico and have them pay for
it I mean that's a sovereignty argument
that's on a similar intellectual level
well I've said that I mean there is an
argument on the other side that when
someone like Shawn called lianca says
borders were the worst invention ever
buy politicians mean that's a bit
extreme as well I mean people's their
identities matters them well I mean
national identity matters but do borders
anymore I mean we look at the
technological revolution or the fourth
Industrial Revolution look at my
children who are 14 and 12 they live
with applications they are pretty much
borderless so of order six vacations but
you know we can also look at migration
across Europe and see that people don't
want they do want borders they want to
stop people coming in says who I mean
this is the thing Britain has says most
boating populations I mean I think
that's a gross exaggeration to be quite
honest I think migratory flows have been
great for all great nation so you look
at the United States you look at the
United Kingdom we all benefit from them
you look at the economic growth that
you've had in the past few years some of
it's actually linked to the migratory
flows we need to I think detach
ourselves from the fears and
insecurities when we talk about
migration I'm not saying that we should
have a completely borderless world but
let's face it it's a good thing that
people move from one country to another
it's a good thing in practice it's a
good thing in
terms of economic performance it's not a
good thing if suddenly everybody in your
street is speaking a different language
and wearing different clothes why not
what's so bad about that it's part of
multiculturalism in many ways I'm not
saying that it goal goes without
problems I'm looking at the NHS in the
UK I'm looking at the schools and the
rest of it but remember that you've been
a great Empire and part of being having
been a great Empire also responsibility
Finland is slowly becoming a
multicultural country the UK is one of
the most multicultural countries in the
world I think humans are of kin and we
should get along now that Britain is
coming out of the European Union do you
think there is a need for a European
army at the European Army is a big word
I think our defense will be based on
NATO in Europe Finland is not a member
of NATO unfortunately but nevertheless
European defence will be based on that
then there will be defence cooperation
the word European army is I think
perhaps a little bit too early but I
mean yeah I did from Finland spot of you
and we all remember you know Pitman's
relationship with the European with the
Soviet Union and Russia of this that
mean huge to certain extent one might
say Finland is on the front line and do
you see with the weakening of the
European Union does that make you worry
about Finland's future in the West
well definitely our security is attached
to the European Union it's basically
based on the pillar of our own
independent and credible defense and
it's based on the European Union and the
bilateral cooperation that we do with
many countries including actually we
just signed an agreement with the UK and
then it's also based on our relationship
with NATO so for Finn to play down
European defense would be stupidity if
we need to play it out if the Russians
were to move against when Finland are
you confident that European allies
including Britain would come to your
rescue and definitely the question is
obviously very hypothetical but to be
quite honest we're members of the euro
we're members of the European Union we
are community of values we also have
security guarantees inside the European
Union I hope and I'm sure that this will
not happen but I do think that the West
is in decline and we need to do
something about it
so thank you very much indeed thanks